chapter four Spider-Man versus himself
what's that about well this is something
that I think every human struggles with
uh certainly Founders certainly I
personally have struggled with this the
idea that if you think about Peter
Parker and there's the whole backstory
of like the Marvel superheroes that
prior to that uh the DC Superheroes were
super they had no flaws but the Marvel
superheroes all were very human and they
had broken sides of so Spider-Man Peter
Parker was this awkward school boy who
had a uh lived with his aunt and uncle
and had a hard time connecting with
girls yet on the other side of that he's
the savior of the city and he's a super
hero that does these incredible things
and it just speaks to the impostor
Phenom which is what it was originally
called before it became the Imposter
syndrome and that within all of us there
is a a worth issue and in this part of
the book I talk about um my bankruptcies
uh how I had over a million dollars of
friends and family money that was in
those bankruptcies and how so much of um
my worth was caught up in in the
businesses you know I had birth this
business and it was a part of my
identity and this is what I believed was
my representation of of my life uh
Mission at the time and I didn't know at
the time that that's broken that
ultimately I'm not my business my
business is a reflection of some of me
but ultimately it's not me altogether
and I just talk about going back through
and what are the belief systems that we
have in terms of if we have results and
actions and attitude that we see above
the surface of a of Our Lives what's
down below what is the in inner
character and what are those belief
systems that drive that and also talk
about that look within all of us there
are uh there's an propensity to
incredible good as well as incredible
bad um you know Alexander soliton I'm
going to paraphrase the quote but he
said if only we could eradicate evil
from uh Humanity but the line of Good
and Evil goes through every human heart
and who's willing to cut away a part of
their heart and it just speaks to that
we all have been given this gift of
imagination and with that we can create
incredible abundance or incredible
scarcity incredible hope or incredible
anxiety we choose and it's a it's
incredible to have that power of choice
and it's also realizing that we all have
it within us and that we need to make
sure that we feed the the wolf so we
talked about in our last podcast the
white wolf and the Dark Wolf that lives
within all of us and the idea that the
the chief and his grandson are talking
and and the grandson says what which one
wins and uh the chief says whichever one
you feed that doesn't mean so if you're
feeding the white wolf of more abundance
and hope and uh building value that
doesn't mean that Dark Wolf ever goes
away it's just pushing it and shrinking
it to as small a part of our being as
possible and our choices daily will
determine um how that happens including
you know things like this your community
like surrounding yourself with people
who actually are either going to be
engines in your life and help build you
up or anchors and drag you down and uh
one of the things I've come to learn
about how do you identify the engines of
your life they're the real friends who
will celebrate with you um so struggles
through struggles and celebration is how
you found your real friends are because
during struggles your real friends will
stand beside you and support you and
celebration being is that when you're
winning that they're actually routing
for you because I've come to learn that
most people want you to win just not
much more than them your real friends
well you can always tell who your real
friends are because when you're winning
they're not
applauding right yes the other thing
that's noticeable too is is is your true
friends will uh like bust your chops and
they'll talk [__] to your face but
they'll always protect you when you're
not around like they'll always manage
your reputation in such a way that
nobody can disparage you you know to
your back if you're in the same room
sort of thing I like what you've sort of
described here because you know it's
funny because we haven't sat together in
a long time and a lot of the
conversations that we used to have in
for and back in the day are some of the
topics that I've talked to my audience
on my channel and now you're sort of
paraphrasing as well like we're talking
about the uh decision sequence between
belief systems choices and results right
and I've covered that many times I can
see you've added that in this chapter
which is a huge relevant point I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out